Good evening, everybody.
I'm Homi Bhaba, director of
the Mahindra Humanities Center,
and I'm absolutely
delighted to welcome you
to the launch of the second
year of our environment forum.
Last year's wide array
of events, including
visits by Terry Tempest
Williams, Jedediah Purdy, Roy
Scranton, Timothy LeCain,
Tiya Miles, and it's
an honor for us to have
our colleague Naomi
Oreskes to lead off this fall.
Before Robin Kelsey
introduces Professor Oreskes,
I wanted to share a few
thoughts on the series
and its importance for us
at the Mahindra Center.
The forum is our attempt to
establish platforms that deal
with areas of study and public
interests that do not fall
within the remit of
any one discipline,
and that we cannot simply in a
facile way designate as being
interdisciplinary.
The fine granularity
of these problems
often emerges in the spaces
in between established bodies
of knowledge.
And this is something that
we're very keen on fostering
and exploring at the
Humanities Center,
these forms of
interstitial knowledge
that question the boundaries
of several disciplinary
configurations.
And out of them
emerge challenges
where we've got to find a
kind of montage of methods
in order to gain some
purchase or perspective.
And the environment forum
really helps us to do this.
You have people who write in
the first person about processes
that are so much larger than any
first person narrative can ever
contain.
So there's this
remarkable energy
between specifying something
that has not been named
and putting around it several
dynamics of knowledge,
subjectification, questions
of value, and so on.
So it's this kind
of interstitial area
for which we really
thank our conveners
of the environmental forum.
And I say this because it's been
my growing sense of what we do
here at the environment forum.
Working with these
interstitial spaces
redefines the relationship
between pedagogical interest
and political action.
So it's not simply
that we're dealing
with a certain way in which
new knowledge is formed,
but it restructures the
articulation of education
and practice and the form
of political calculation
and judgment.
The study of the
environment presents us
with the challenge
of having to secure
a language of description that
finds its network, its voice,
in a continually circulating
network of dialogues.
The dominant motif
of these events
has been the profound issue
of the care of the planet,
[INAUDIBLE],, a form of care
that Heidegger, amongst others,
has elaborated in being in time.
Care as a form of ethical
attention and vigilant
interpretation is at the
very core of the project
of the humanities.
And to the extent to
which an ethic of care
is fundamental to the
survival of planetary life,
the environment
forum is at the core
of the work of the
Mahindra Center.
I don't think that
there has ever
been a time which has made
this whole question of care
as an ethical, but also as
a careful textual project
more urgent or apparent.
There is such a
widespread carelessness
of the lives of the
people, a carelessness
towards the planet, a
carelessness towards truth,
a carelessness
towards interpretation
coupled in the last months
with remarkable ecological and
environmental crises.
It's almost as if nature
is standing up and saying,
we cannot have this any longer.
And in these crises,
what becomes visible
are the great deficits
of planetary care,
but also the great deficits
of citizenly carefulness.
And it is in that
spirit that I'm
very happy to welcome
you to the launch
event of the second year
of the environment forum,
and I want to thank my dear
friends and colleagues Robin
Kelsey and Ian
Miller for helping
us to build this argument.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm Robin Kelsey, dean
of Arts and Humanities,
And with Ian Miller a
co-convener of the environment
forum, the mission
of which has just
been articulated with
unprecedented eloquence
by Homi Bhaba.
And I want to thank Homi for
embracing the environment
forum, for coming
to these events,
for thinking hard
about this project,
and for on this occasion
such a brilliant articulation
of what we are about.
I also want to thank Steve
Biel and Sarah Razor, who have
done so much to bring this on.
Yes.
[APPLAUSE] I am convinced there
is more than one Sarah Razor,
but she always
looks much the same.
So this university, 391
years old and counting,
has a motto that consists
of a single word, veritas.
Harvard presumably
pursues many values,
but the isolation in our
motto of this one value,
truth, implicitly
acknowledges how easy
it would be to muddy
our own waters,
to lose our sense of
direction and purpose,
to drift down some easier path.
The Harvard motto I think
rightly understood tacitly
recognizes that the
pursuit of truth
requires grit and courage
as well as curiosity.
And no one at Harvard
exemplifies this combination
of qualities better
than Naomi Oreskes.
Professor of the history
of science at Harvard
as well as an
affiliate of the earth
and planetary sciences,
Professor Oreskes
has, by virtue of her gritty
and courageous pursuit of truth,
become a crucial agent of
our collective conscience.
Along with her frequent
co-author Eric Conway,
a historian at the Jet
Propulsion Lab at Caltech,
Professor Oreskes has clarified
the state of our knowledge
about human-induced
climate change,
exposed the hidden
apparatus that
obfuscates and misrepresents
that knowledge,
and has offered a
bleak but all too sober
assessment of where our
carelessness, to use
Homi's term, may lead
our planet and ourselves.
With respect to climate
change, in other words,
if we have any grasp
of where things stand
and the challenges
we face, we owe it
in no small part to
Professor Oreskes.
A holder of a BS degree from
the Royal School of Mines--
I did not know this
actually before I started
preparing this introduction.
I found that an absolutely
delightful piece
of information.
A holder of a BS degree from the
Royal School of Mines Imperial
College of London, and a
PhD from Stanford, Professor
Oreskes is the author or
co-author of several books,
and a common thread
running through them
is an insistence
on understanding
how the production of
knowledge and the contestation
that that production
entails actually happens.
Along with other leading
historians of science,
she has countered a
longstanding tendency
to confuse the justification
for scientific theories
with the histories by which
those theories have obtained
their scientific standing.
In her first book, The Rejection
of Continental Drift, Theory
and Method in American
Earth Science,
She argues convincingly
that a significant portion
of this confusion stems from
an excessively monolithic
understanding of the
scientific method.
Indeed, she demonstrates
that American geoscientists
were so resistant to the
theory of continental drift
precisely because it
challenged the way that they
went about their work.
It's a wonderful
piece of scholarship
in the history of science.
Working with Conway,
Professor Oreskes
produced the 2010 book
Merchants of Doubt,
a phrase that has entered
the lexicon of many of us.
A book that demonstrated that
a small number of scientists
with strong ties to industry
and to industry-friendly parts
of our political establishment
have over decades served
to obscure scientific
consensus and sew
doubts in the populace
at large about
robust scientific inferences.
The coterie of experts,
scientists of high standing
who have, however, no
particular expertise
in the matter in question,
has time and again slowed
political recognition of a
range of dangerous practices
from cigarette smoking
to fossil fuel burning.
And as we experience the
onset of post-truth politics,
Merchants of Doubt is
more important than ever.
And I'm very much
looking forward
to seeing how this segue
is made this evening.
More recently,
Oreskes and Conway
wrote The Collapse of
Western Civilization, a View
From the Future, a work
of speculative fiction
that makes vivid the possible
costs of our ongoing failure
to address our climate problem.
And I know Ian uses
this in his teaching
and has wonderful
stories to tell
about how generative it is.
In addition to her
books, Professor Oreskes
has produced numerous articles
both in scholarly journals
and the popular press.
She is a public intellectual
of the most necessary kind,
and she is here this evening to
talk to us about giant power.
A giant power herself,
please join me
in welcoming Naomi Oreskes.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much for
that incredibly generous
introduction.
But as you can see,
I'm not giant at all.
[LAUGHTER] But on
the other hand, I did
pick up some grit at the
Royal School of Mines.
So it's really a pleasure to be
here and see so many new faces.
And also it's great
to be introduced
as a poster child
for interstitiality
because earlier in my career I
was just considered a problem.
You know, deans didn't
know where to put me.
One dean once told me I
had the strangest resume
he'd ever seen.
So it's actually
incredibly gratifying
to feel that the world has kind
of come around to my vision.
So thank you very much.
I'm feeling very
satisfied tonight.
Of course, that's a bad thing.
You should never
feel self-satisfied.
So with that, we get to work.
So many of you are familiar
with the comedian John Oliver.
And some of you may
have seen the routine
he did a few months back
where he got really vexed
about the fact that many
Americans don't accept
the reality of climate change.
And he noted that
one in four Americans
are skeptical-- or is
skeptical-- about climate
change.
And he said, "who gives a shit?
That doesn't matter.
You don't need people's
opinion on a fact.
You might as well have a poll
asking which number is bigger,
5 or 15?
Do owls exist?
Or are there hats?"
Now although I love John Oliver,
unfortunately as a historian
I have to acknowledge that there
is, in fact, a long history
of arguing about whether
there are hats, so to speak,
and of trying to persuade
the American people that five
actually might be a
bigger number than 15.
So just to give you one
example out of my work
on the history of
climate change,
Oliver was of course
referring to climate change,
and in particular he has
gone on several rants
about the recent
claim that many of us
heard repeatedly during the
last election, the claim
that global warming
had stopped in 1998.
Now, these are the actual
historic temperature records
going back to 1880.
But one thing we know
is that you can actually
get people to think about
numbers in very different ways
simply by the way
you present them.
So for example, my
colleague Steve Lewandowski
did an extremely interesting
experiment a few years ago.
These are the global
temperature data,
again, going back to 1880,
plotted in this graph showing
a five year running mean.
But he labeled it world
agricultural output.
And he asked people this,
what is the trend since 1998?
And they all answered that
output continued to rise,
which is the correct answer.
But if you show
them this graph, you
get a very different answer.
This is what we call
the skeptic's graph
of global warming.
If you show them this, people
will tell you they don't know
or the temperatures didn't rise.
So this presentation is used
by many climate change skeptics
and deniers to confuse
people about what's
actually happening with the
numbers, 5 and 15, or 1 and 2.
Put more generally,
we have ample evidence
that it's actually pretty easy
to get people arguing about
whether or not there are hats.
Now, how do you
get people to argue
about the existence
of hats is largely
a social scientific question.
But why people have
done so and for what
purposes I want to argue
is primarily a question
of history and culture.
And so today I want to
talk about the new work
I'm doing on the history of
disinformation long duree.
And I was hoping David Armitage
was here so that I could boast
about doing long duree history.
But in any event--
and to talk about it
specifically in the relation
to the question of the defense
of free market capitalism
in the United States.
Because it turns out that these
two things are very closely
related.
So I'm going to
talk to you today
about a new project
that I call Inventing
the Magic of the Marketplace.
We could also call it the long
history of post-facticity.
I'm particularly interested
in post-facticity
in the private sector.
That is to say I'm not that
interested in the history
of politicians lying, I
think that's pretty familiar.
But there's a different history
that I think is extremely
important of actors in the
private sector-- businessmen,
PR, advertising
companies, think tanks--
who have been
involved in this it
turns out for a very long time.
So some initial observations.
This pattern of private
sector disinformation
is repeatedly linked to two
key and interrelated aims.
One is to stop or
limit regulation
of particular industries such
as electricity or tobacco,
and the other is to
protect the private sector
from responsibility for
external costs of their products
like air pollution, water
pollution, climate change.
But the defense of
the private sector
through propaganda
and disinformation
has repeatedly involved
tropes of freedom
and the American way of life,
and has been repeatedly linked
to the defense of
laissez faire capitalism
in the early 20th century--
or what we tend to call
neoliberalism later--
and the repeated argument
that the American way of life
is inextricably bound to
enterprise capitalism.
So this is a cultural
question, and so that's
one reason why I was keen to
give this talk here tonight
at the Humanities Center.
Now, Robin already referred
to my work with Erik Conway.
In Merchants of Doubt, we showed
how this argument about freedom
and the American way of
life was developed and honed
by the tobacco industry, and
then how a group of actors
applied these arguments
to a set of issues
in the late 20th century,
including acid rain, the ozone
hole, the regulation of DDT,
and of course, climate change.
We identified a specific
strategy which we saw
used repeatedly, to
cast doubt on facts
that show the harms
of your product,
insist that the
science is unsettled,
to recruit experts to give
your otherwise obviously
self-interested
position credibility,
to impugn the motives
of your opponents,
and to assert that their actions
threaten American freedom,
hence the use of the
term watermelons,
that they're green on the
outside but red on the inside.
So in our research, we
traced these arguments
from current and recent
debates about climate change
back to the tobacco industry.
And we showed
through our research
how the same think
tanks, the same PR
firms, the same advertising
agencies, and sometimes
even the same
people were involved
in attacking the science
showing the harms of tobacco
and the science showing
the harms of fossil fuel
combustion.
And we showed how they linked
the defense of harmful products
to the defense of free market
capitalism, and from there
to the defense of
freedom generally.
So just to give one example,
this is one of my favorite ones
from a report defending
the tobacco industry
and attacking the science
related to secondhand smoke.
The scientists who
wrote this piece, one
of our merchants of doubt,
actually laid it on the line
and he wrote, quote,
"if we do not carefully
delineate the government's
role in regulating dangers,
there's essentially
no limit to how much
government can ultimately
control our lives."
So there's the
argument in a nutshell,
and people often ask me,
well, are these people
just shills for industry?
How do they sleep at night?
How do they understand
what they're doing?
It's a complicated story.
The answer is not the
same for everyone.
But I think this
argument helps to explain
how people can take
these positions
and view them as principled.
But although it may be
principled for an individual,
it gets used in an
extremely unprincipled way.
So I thought I would just show
you a small clip from our film,
from the film version
of Merchants of Doubt,
because I'm an extremely
lucky academic.
If you don't read my book,
I can show you the movie.
So I'm going to just show
you a clip that really shows
how this argument about freedom
was exploited by the tobacco
industry, and then
we'll move on to looking
at this longer older history.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- The tobacco
companies knew you have
to appeal to
something more basic
than this intellectual
pursuit of science.
And how do you do it?
You do it with freedom.
- That's the way freedom dies.
Today it's smoking, but what
will they try to regulate next?
- What will they try
to regulate next?
What we can say,
what we can read?
- I don't want Big
Brother breathing down
my neck telling me what to do.
- Not just for the smokers, but
for non-smokers and all others
in this country who want to live
their lives making their own
decisions not having them made
for them by the benevolent
bureaucracy of Washington
wisdom or these other folks--
- By turning it into an
abstract issue of freedom
and moving it away
from protecting
their corporate interests,
they can get people behind it.
I mean, who's could
possibly be against freedom?
And then what happened
was these other companies
in other industries
realized, like,
hey, that's a pretty good idea.
- Everywhere you
turn, somebody's
telling us what we can't eat.
Do you ever feel
like you're always
being told what not to do?
- These are people
that want to tell us
where to work, how many
children we can have,
how much energy we can use,
how much water we can have--
- Looking at the
global warming issue,
you're seeing the
same thing happening.
- For literally
decades, David Koch
has been just a
tireless defender
of our economic and
individual freedoms.
I'd like to introduce
to you David
Koch, our chairman at the
Americans for Prosperity.
- Koch industries
is heavily invested
in coal, oil, tar sands.
They are some of the biggest
polluters in the country,
have received some
of the largest fines.
- They needed an army of people
to fight against regulation
in the name of freedom.
- Good afternoon,
fellow freedom fighters!
[END PLAYBACK]
OK, so you get the picture.
So this is Americans for
Prosperity, otherwise known
as the Tea Party.
And the motif, the
repeated motif is,
this is about freedom.
So today what I
want to talk about
is my new work that begins
to extend this analysis.
And I want to say,
Erik Conway and I
were pretty excited
when we realized
that we could trace
climate change now back
to the tobacco industry.
We thought that was,
like, pretty amazing.
And I should have
realized as a historian
that if you look deeper,
though, you can always
find the earlier antecedents.
So that's really what
this work is today,
to look at some even
earlier antecedents.
So I want to begin by talking
about an advertising campaign
from the 1960s that warned
of a grave impending threat
to American freedom.
So one advertisement shown
here asked the question,
how is freedom lost?
Another answered the
question, freedom
is not lost by guns alone.
And you can see this is the
Berlin Wall here being shown.
Another ad asked, will
you leave these freedoms
to your children?
And it identified four key
freedoms symbolized here
by a Bible, a key, a
pencil, and the ballot.
The Bible representing, of
course, freedom of religion,
the key representing
the right to privacy,
the pencil representing
the right to free speech
and free expression, and the
ballot representing the right
to democratic governance.
And this advertisement
told us that half the world
is trying to destroy
these four symbols
and what they stand for.
So what were these
advertisements for?
Well if you hadn't seen
the title of my talk
you might think--
or maybe even still think
a political party, maybe
Barry Goldwater; an
anti-communist group, maybe
the John Birch Society;
maybe a campaign
against the campaign
for nuclear disarmament;
maybe an American church.
But the answer is electricity.
This was an advertising campaign
defending electricity generated
in the private sector
against electricity generated
in municipally owned utilities
or federal power generation
schemes.
And the argument had
two major components.
The first was ostensibly
a factual claim.
It was the claim that
government run electricity
was more expensive than
private sector electricity.
And therefore, it was not
in the public interest
to have publicly-funded or
publicly-managed electricity
products.
So for example
this ad asked, how
can we save taxpayers
half a billion dollars?
The answer, don't build
federal hydropower projects.
This ad informed us that
American families paid over
$5 trillion a year to
support public power.
And at the bottom, it
may be cut off there,
but it said in capital letters,
when public power wins,
you lose.
But the advertisement
was also ideological.
It wasn't just about the cost
of federal hydroelectric dams
or other things like that.
It was also the argument that
government-run electricity
was a threat to American
freedom and democracy.
So again, if we go
back to this ad,
we already talked about the
idea of these key freedoms.
And some ads join these
two themes together.
So this is my favorite one.
This one tells us that
there are actually
two kinds of electricity.
You might not know that
from your light bulb,
because you wouldn't be
able to see the difference.
But actually there's
a big difference
between electricity
from an electric company
versus the electricity
from the government.
Company electricity is better
than government electricity
because it's cheaper, because it
pays taxes rather than imposing
them, because it's
available to everyone
without discrimination, and
most importantly because it
plays a key role in America's
free enterprise system.
And I love this advertisement
because the pretty woman
represents the private sector
and this dumbfounded man
represents the government.
One interesting thing
about these advertisements
is that they inverted
conventional notions
of public and private, referring
to privately held shareholder
owned companies as public, but
putting public in scare quotes
and claiming that public power
wasn't actually public at all,
it was government power.
So there's a kind of
jujitsu move here.
The private sector is
equated with the public,
as in British public
schools, but public powers
asserted not actually to be in
the hands of the public at all,
but an interfering, incompetent,
and wasteful government.
The key argument is that by
interfering in the marketplace,
the government is threatening
our private property
and personal freedom, as
well as wasting our money.
Now, these ads
were from the 1960s
but the same argument had
made before in the 1920s
by an organization known as
NELA, the National Electric
Light Association.
By the 1960s, many Americans
had forgotten about this earlier
campaign, but it essentially
took the same form.
Public power's more
expensive, public power's
a threat to freedom, it's
unsound, socialistic,
and fundamentally un-American,
and anyone who advocates it
must be a socialist or worse.
So who were NELA?
NELA was a trade organization
first established in the 1880s
but expanded and strengthened
under the influence
of the Chicago
industrialist Thomas Insull,
who was one of the
leaders in the development
of electrification of
the city of Chicago.
NELA represented the
holding companies
that in the late 19th
and early 20th century
owned most local private
electricity utilities.
In the 1930s they were
investigated by the Federal
Trade Commission in a series
of investigations that led
to about 30 volumes of reports.
The FTC found that NELA had
organized a massive propaganda
campaign designed to discredit
municipal electricity
and impugn the motives of
those who supported it.
They concluded that holding
companies had, in fact, been
engaged in many speculative
financial activities
and were a major source
of political corruption.
Now in hindsight, many
of these activities
are actually very similar to
the things for which the tobacco
industry was prosecuted
under the Rico statutes,
but Rico had not yet
been passed as a law.
So they couldn't be prosecuted
for most of these activities.
There was no law that
made these things illegal,
but they were greatly
constrained after 1935
by the passage of
the Holding Company
Act, which interestingly
enough was repealed in 2005.
Now in hindsight, historians
who have studied this episode
have concluded that the central
claims that NELA put forward
were factually untrue.
That, in fact, private power
was generally more costly
and that this was known
and documented at the time,
and that public power, when it
was implemented under the New
Deal in rural electrification in
the Tennessee Valley Authority,
well, the federal
government did grow,
but the United States did
not become communistic.
Although some people
might argue that point.
So here's an
interesting question.
Why did the electricity
industry think
they needed this
propaganda campaign?
Well, there were
three main issues
that were motivating them.
One was the problem of
rural electrification,
the second was the
problem of what
constituted a reasonable
rate for electricity,
and the third were
these allegations
of questionable practices.
So as many of you probably
know, power generation
in the United States was mainly
developed as a private sector
activity which contrasted
to other countries
like Germany, France,
Japan, and New
Zealand, where the government
was much more involved.
It was a huge success in urban
areas like New York, Chicago,
and St. Louis.
The private sector was
very effective in bringing
electricity to citizens
in major urban areas.
But rural areas of
America remained
largely underserved, or in some
cases, completely unserved.
And where they were
served they were often
too expensive for rural
citizens, particularly farmers,
to afford.
And the fact that it was
too expensive for farmers
became a topic of conversation
because many people
argued that while it was all
very well and good to light up
the Empire State Building
or have lighting displays
at the St. Louis
World's Fair, it
was farmers who really needed
electricity for the hard work
that they did on their farms.
So in response to this lack
of electricity in rural areas,
some farmers developed
cooperatives,
and there was
increasing pressure
for the federal government to
become involved in electricity.
And indeed, there were a
couple of major projects
such as the Muscle Shoals
project, which historians have
written a lot about, the
Hoover Dam, and ultimately
the Tennessee Valley Authority
and rural electrification,
although that came later.
The second was the issue
of reasonable rates.
Electricity was
widely recognized
as being what was known at that
time as a natural monopoly.
That is to say, an industry in
which competition didn't really
make sense because it would
be wasteful and impractical
to have multiple
electricity lines running
through a city or a rural area.
So companies were
given franchises
that were regulated by state
commissions on the same model
as the railroads,
which were also
viewed as natural monopolies.
The commissions would
set what were known to be
or thought to be
reasonable and fair rates,
and that was based on the idea
of a reasonable rate of return,
which was generally
thought to be 5% to 6%.
But there was
considerable evidence
that companies were overcharging
and actually garnering
returns of 7%,
8%, or 9%, in part
by exaggerating
their operating costs
and using this to
justify higher rates.
In fact, there was evidence that
public electricity was cheaper,
and the prime case was
Ontario Hydro Power.
In Canada, Ontario had
developed a system of hydropower
that was publicly owned
and it had broad power
to most residents of
Ontario at much lower cost
than across the border in New
York City or Pennsylvania.
So very similar
cultural situation.
Electricity was much more
widely available in Ontario
and cheaper than it
was in upstate New York
or Pennsylvania.
And this was used
as evidence that, A,
the industry was
charging too much, and B,
that public generation might
be more cost effective.
The third was this issue
of questionable financial
practices.
The holding companies
were accused of stock
watering-- issuing stock
in excess of company value
and using this to justify
higher rates; of exaggerating
their operating costs; of
bribing local officials;
and creating various unstable
financial instruments which
in 1929 were argued to have
contributed to the crash.
So what was the
solution to these three
interrelated problems?
Well, a number of people began
to argue that the solution was
for the government to
become more involved
in electricity markets.
One I've already
mentioned, the idea
of federal electricity
generation projects
like Muscle Shoals
and the Hoover Dam.
And often these were
proposed in conjunction
with flood control
and irrigation,
which were broadly viewed as
legitimate federal functions.
There were also proposals for
a federal regulatory system
on the grounds that a
federal system would not
be as easily corrupted and
influenced as a local one.
Another argument, however,
was a state-based response.
And one of the most
interesting ones at this time
was something
called giant power.
This was a proposal
to create a system
of integrated statewide
electrical power
in Pennsylvania.
Giant Power was not proposed by
a group of radical communists
or the International
Workers of the World,
but rather by Gifford Pinchot,
the governor of Pennsylvania,
who as many of you know was
the first head of the US Forest
Service and a great advocate
of rational management
of natural resources.
He worked in conjunction with
Morris Llewellyn Cooke, who
was a mechanical engineer in the
tailorist tradition-- so again,
rational analysis of industry
and manufacturing-- and Cooke
later became the head of rural
electrification in the New Deal
under President Roosevelt.
Both of these men were
progressive Republicans,
although Cooke did
later become a Democrat
under Roosevelt.
Both were advocates
of progressive-era scientific
management of industry
and national resources.
So they were progressives,
but they were not radicals.
So what was the idea?
Giant Power was
proposed in 1923,
and the idea was that you
would build power plants right
at coal mines--
at the coal mouth, as it was--
and then you would
feed that electricity
into a statewide grid
that would offer power
to all residents of the
state of Pennsylvania
at fair and equitable rates.
Private companies
could still operate,
but they would be forced
into the state-wide pool.
And all citizens would be
served power at the same rates.
And the state would create a
strong regulatory commission
to oversee the project.
Now, why was this needed?
Well, I've already said fair
pricing was one major issue.
But the bigger issue
really was access.
So I've already
talked about this.
Gifford Pinchot was particularly
interested in the problem
of getting
electricity to farmers
who he felt really needed it.
Indeed, at this point
already electricity
was coming to be seen not as
a luxury, but as a necessity.
Not as a privilege, but a right.
And increasingly
it was also seen
in a kind of technophilic
utopian vision
as the foundation
for improvement
in the quality of the lives
of the American people.
So in 1925, for example,
Pinchot wrote, "Giant Power
is a plan to bring cheaper and
better electric service to all
those who have it
now, and to bring
good and cheap electric
service to those
who are still without it.
It is a plan by which most
of the drudgery of human life
can be taken from the shoulders
of men and women who toil
and replaced by the
power of electricity."
The industry considered
this to be a huge threat.
The electricity industry
was growing rapidly,
and was highly profitable,
and as I've already mentioned,
was developed in
the United States
as a private sector activity.
But there were competing
models from other places,
and the industry worried
that the United States might
actually squeeze out
the private generator
and replace it with a federally
or state controlled system.
Giant Power was drawing
on these other models,
and it did seek
deliberately to, quote,
"change the direction
of the utility industry"
as the historian of
technology Tom Hughes
wrote many years ago.
Industry opponents viewed
it as an unfair taking,
as socialistic, and a threat
to freedom, as well as a threat
to their profits.
So the Pennsylvania Electric
Association wrote, quote--
that's a typo, sorry--
"The clear purpose
of this plan is
to take from any
electric service system
the benefits it has
thus far accrued
by reason of able management,
successful financing,
painstaking research
work, and courage
in the replacement of apparatus.
Private initiative
is to be supplanted
by a political plan based
on a socialistic theory
and offering the possibilities
of the construction
of a statewide all-powerful
political machine."
Now, the proponents here were
invoking what the historian
David Noble has called
technological Darwinism,
the argument that because
the electricity had developed
in a certain way to date that
this was necessarily the best
way, and it was the result
of the hard work and fitness
of the able managers and smart
financers, smart investors
who had done this.
We could argue about whether
or not those claims were true,
but whether or not they
were, one could certainly
imagine a rational argument
about the pros and cons
of private and
public sector systems
and a rational discussion
of how to get electricity
to rural customers who were
not well-served by the existing
system.
But that's not what happened.
Instead, NELA launched a
massive propaganda campaign
to discredit Giant Power, to
discredit Gifford Pinchot,
and to discredit
any form of publicly
generated or distributed
electrical power,
whether on the municipal,
state, or federal level.
So what did they do?
Well, according to the
Federal Trade Commission,
everything but sky writing.
They targeted newspapers
and other print media,
supplying press releases,
articles, editorials,
many of which were written
by third party allies--
that is to say,
people who didn't
appear to have a link to
the electricity industry,
but in fact were being paid.
They attempted to influence
radio, film, and theater.
They launched attack on
politicians like Pinchot who
supported Giant Power or
other public projects,
so similar to what we've seen
the Americans for Prosperity
do today.
But really interestingly,
particularly
for us with our
motto of veritas,
their largest focus was actually
us, the educational system,
high school and
higher education.
And in particular they
focused on textbooks.
NELA undertook a survey of
all the existing high school
and college texts that
were being used in civics
and economics classrooms.
And then they began to
pressure publishers, colleges,
and universities, and school
districts, and libraries
to drop text that they
considered objectionable.
So what made a
textbook objectional?
Well NELA claimed that the
texts were not objective
or that they were socialistic.
But if we look at the
documentary evidence,
we begin to see
that actually they
objected to almost
anything the cast
industry in an unflattering
light or anything that
suggested that there could
be a place for publicly
generated electricity.
I think I'm going
to kind of skip
through some of the details
about some of the things
that they objected to, but
here's a list of terms,
so specific terms that
NELA found objectionable
in textbooks.
Over-capitalization,
stock watering,
abuses in rate
making, weaknesses
in regulatory practices,
reasonable rates, fair return,
or even the term public utility.
So anything that
suggested that there
might be a problem, that
the industry was less
than completely honest, or
less than completely fair,
or that even there was a
concept of a fair return, all
of these terms were
considered objectionable.
So what did they do?
They began to target the
authors of these textbooks
and offered them money to write
new editions of the books.
And if they agreed to do it,
which many did because, sure,
who wouldn't want to
update their textbook
and be paid for it, right?
Then after they had
agreed, then they
sent them a list of suggestions
for suggested changes.
If the authors said no,
they weren't interested,
then they hired other authors
to write alternative textbooks.
And the consistent pattern
and theme in these books
was to promote the ideology
of free market capitalism.
And then once the
textbooks were written,
they sent free copies
to schools, colleges,
libraries across the country,
and began to pressure schools
to adopt them, arguing that the
existing textbooks were biased,
and anti-American,
and socialistic,
but the new textbook was
fairer and more objective.
They also funded academic
studies in universities
to prove that public power was
more expensive than private.
And once these
studies were done,
then they heavily promoted
them to the press,
through press releases,
bulletins, and funded lecture
tours.
So someone would agree
to write a report that
was favorable to
the industry, then
they would pay for
them to go on a lecture
tour around the country.
And they worked to
develop curricula
at colleges and
universities in America.
And I am actually-- in
some written materials,
I actually have a list of the
universities that are involved,
and it's really scary,
and it includes Harvard.
So they developed
specific courses--
in some cases, whole curricula--
in economics and business
administration.
And the purpose,
in their own words,
was, quote, "to ensure straight
economic thinking," by which
they meant capitalistic
free-market laissez faire
principles, and to
ensure the possession
by young people and
their teachers of, quote,
"correct information."
And they even gave funding
to establish departments
in schools, one of which was
the Harvard School of Business.
So I can't wait to
get into the archives
to look at these materials.
So what would constitute
success in their view?
Quote, "When judges, lawmakers,
members of the public utility
commissions, prosecuting
attorneys, and engineers--
in short, all public officials--
will be so trained
as automatically
to oppose genuine
regulation, public ownership,
honest valuations,
equitable rates, et cetera."
When I read that paragraph,
I couldn't help but think
of this document from 1998
when the American Petroleum
Institute issued a
document that said,
victory will be achieved
when average citizens quote,
"Understand--" slash
recognize-- "uncertainties
in climate science,
recognition of uncertainties
becomes part of the
conventional wisdom,
the media understands
uncertainties
in climate science.
And if we go down to the bottom,
those promoting the Kyoto
Treaty on the basis
of extant science
appear to be out of
touch with reality."
Now in all these
activities, they often
work through, as I've already
mentioned, third party allies--
other groups or
other individuals
to try to hide or minimize
the NELA connection.
And particularly
this was true when
they funded academic studies.
They would try to
hide the funding.
So a report would come
out, but it would nowhere
disclose that the report had
been wholly funded by NELA.
And this was obviously to make
the studies appear independent,
and therefore
objective and credible.
The FTC concluded not just that
this was a propaganda campaign,
but that it was the largest
peacetime propaganda
campaign in US history.
And academics had played
a key role, especially
academic administrators, many
of whom had welcomed NELA help,
enthusiastically accepting
NELA funds to develop
courses and departments.
So Robin Kelsey,
I'm looking at you.
But you know, I think we've
all seen this happen, right?
And as I've already
said, experts
who are used then to lend
credibility to these reports.
So I think it's pretty obvious--
I don't think I
have to belabor--
that there are an awful
lot of similarities
to recent developments.
In recent years we've
seen how creationists
have written
textbooks of their own
and put pressure on school
districts and publishers
to adopt these textbooks,
or to use textbooks
that they consider
unobjectionable textbooks that
raise the uncertainties
in evolutionary biology.
We've shown and we know how
the tobacco industry funded
so-called expert studies to
prove that tobacco was not
harmful, and to create
competing facts and narratives.
And of course, in the
area of climate change
denial, the repeated accusation
that climate scientists
are socialists.
Or my favorite one
is when I was accused
by Professor-- professor,
ha ha, wishful thinking.
I was accused by
Senator James Inhofe
of being part of the
liberal conspiracy
to bring down global
capitalism, to which I respond,
liberals should be so organized.
The NELA's strategy is
really the Merchants
of Doubt strategy.
It didn't begin with
the tobacco industry.
It's actually much older.
Cast doubt upon adverse facts
about your product or industry,
impugn the motives and
credibility of those
who are making
factually based claims,
accuse them of being
socialists and communists,
and insist that it's
the government that's
threatening your freedom, and
that the private sector is
actually what's preserving,
protecting, and defending it.
And recruit third
party allies, or even
create entire front
organizations.
So if we go skip again
back to the present,
one of the front organizations
that Erik Conway and I studied
was a group called TASSC, The
Advancement of Sound Science
Coalition.
This is a group that promoted
the idea that policy should
be based on sound science.
And who could
argue against that?
Who wouldn't agree that
public policy should
be based on sound science?
Except the problem is
that TASSC actually
was a wholly created
organization,
a front organization for the
Philip Morris tobacco company.
They hired a PR firm,
APCO Associates ,
and there's a really interesting
materials about this in which
they actually talk about
why they need to hire APCO,
because their previous PR
agency, Burson-Marsteller,
was now viewed as too obviously
associated with the tobacco
giant.
This was launched
in November 1993
with press releases and calls to
journalists around the country.
John Boltz, a manager of media
affairs at Philip Morris,
supplied APCO with a list
of sympathetic journalists.
But APCO, not Boltz,
would place the calls,
quote, "to remove any
possible link to PM," i.e.
Philip Morris.
Among TASSC's activity was
they created a sound science
in journalism award.
And the first award was granted
to New York Times reporter Gina
Kolata who they said,
quote, "had responsibly
detailed how science has
been distorted or manipulated
to fuel litigation on
silicone breast implants."
What they didn't
tell you was that one
of the principal
funders of TASSC
was Dow Corning, the
maker of breast implants.
So let me step back
now from this history
and talk a little bit,
then, about the larger
problem of post-truth America.
I think it's obvious from
what I've shown you today,
and I think most
historians would say this,
that post-truth
isn't post at all.
The term post-truth may
be new, but the practices
associated with it are not.
What we see here is actually
a century-old pattern
of disinformation
aimed at promoting
the interests of private
capital by confusing people
about facts regarding
their products
and by demonizing
the alternatives,
in part by asserting that
those alternatives threaten
American freedom.
So what is the relationship
to us, to the humanities
and the Humanities Center?
Well, I'm an unusual academic.
I'm not competitive.
I don't like having
something all to myself.
I like company.
I like friends.
I'm sociable.
I would like you all to get
involved in this project.
Because I think there are
some giant questions here
that we have not
engaged with in the way
that we could and should
in really profitable ways.
So this is a complicated story.
I've only just shown you a few
little tidbits, a few details.
Hopefully a couple
of years from now
I can tell you a much
richer and fuller story.
But this is, even
with these tidbits,
we see that this is
a very complex story
at the nexus of science,
technology, politics, economy,
money, and power, in both senses
of the word-- electrical power
and political power, which
have been closely linked
this country for 100 years.
But humanities scholars I
think have been a bit slow
to study this and
similar issues.
There's very little humanities
literature on tobacco,
and only recently has there
been much on climate change.
The most famous
intervention in my field,
which is STS, history of
science, on creationism,
is the sociologist Steve Fuller.
So I guess he's a sociologist.
So maybe he doesn't count.
But in STS, Steve Fuller,
who defends creationists.
NELA was the subject of a major
set of federal investigations
in the 1930s.
30 volumes of materials.
And yet there is no recent
secondary literature on it
at all.
I first discovered
this by rereading
Tom Hughes's book, Networks
of Power, published in 1983,
and David Nye's book,
Electrifying America,
published in 1990.
In Hughes' book,
it's a footnote.
In Nye there's a
paragraph, a few sentences.
But this is a story
about power and values.
It's not just about electricity.
Many environmental
issues are fundamentally
issues of power and values.
So you might think
the humanists would
be at the forefront of the
analysis of these issues.
As Homi said at the
start of this evening,
these are issues about
care, about. what
we care about and what
we should be caring for,
and what we're not caring for.
But by and large we haven't
been at the forefront
of these issues.
So why have humanities
scholars paid relatively little
attention to these
juicy, and interesting,
and important topics?
So I want to just throw
out a few ideas, mainly
just to provoke conversation.
Because I think there
is a conversation
that we need to have about this.
And I say this in part based
on my experience teaching
and the way my students
react to these questions.
And so I call this the shadows
of symmetry and postmodernism.
When I first started talking
about the findings that became
the book Merchants of Doubt--
this is now going back 10
years--
I found that my historical
colleagues were actually
very interested,
because historians
are interested in
power, and politics.
And so it wasn't a hard sell to
get my colleagues, for example,
in US history to be interested.
But my colleagues in
science studies and STS
were extremely uncomfortable.
And some said out
loud that they thought
I was violating the
symmetry principle.
Now, does everybody
here know what that is?
No, OK.
So in science studies, one of
the most influential figures
in our field is David Bloor,
who early on back in the 1970s
promoted what he called the
strong program in sociology
of science.
And he argued that good
sociology of science, good STS,
had to be symmetrical, by which
he meant that we should treat
the causes of true
and false beliefs,
we should look for the
same kinds of causes
in explaining both
true and false beliefs.
So we should be examining both
empirical and social causes,
but we should not presuppose
that a true belief is caused
by empirical evidence
but a false belief
is caused by social
interests, that we should not
make that presupposition.
I'll say more about
that in a minute.
But it wasn't just colleagues,
it was students, too.
Even today students
who come into history
of science out of
STS backgrounds
sometimes explicitly
say that they, quote,
"think were not allowed" to say
that the electricity industry
claims were false,
that we're not allowed
to use the word false or
true, and that we're not
allowed to say that
public power in fact costs
less than private electricity.
And the phrase, not
allowed, is a phrase
I have heard in my classroom
more than once, which
I have to say I find
extremely disturbing to think
that in a great
university we're not
allowed to say certain
things, whatever they are.
But especially when
we're not allowed
to use the word true,
or false, or fact.
So recently my student, Eric
Baker, who's here tonight--
stand up and be counted, Eric--
and I wrote an
article, and I call
it Truth Without Scare Quotes.
The argument here
is that the idea
that our disciplinary
commitments do not
permit us to say that
one side of a debate
has facts or even the
weight of evidence as
judged by scientific
experts on its side,
or to suggest that a settled
scientific consensus might
bear some kind of meaningful
relationship to truth.
More broadly, we can
characterize this
as a sort of reticence even
to invoke cognitive categories
or to discuss truth without
putting the word in scare
quotes.
And my students
who are here will
know what I'm talking about.
Now, I want to make a really
important point here and be
clear about what I'm saying.
This is not an argument
against symmetry
as a methodological
starting point.
My own work is deeply
influenced by David Bloor.
I think his argument in
science and social imagery,
which was first
published in 1979,
was an incredibly
important intervention.
But he was arguing
that we should
consider both epistemic and
social factors in our analyses
and not prejudge which was more
pertinent in any given case.
And so I already explained this.
And I agree.
I think that was a very
important intervention
and rightly influential.
But I think that a good deal
of science studies literature,
including some
canonical work, there's
been a conflation of symmetry
as a methodological starting
point--
that is to say, what is your
initial assumption approaching
a problem--
versus an empirical endpoint.
That is to say, it's one thing
to say we shouldn't prejudge
the case, but it's
another thing to say
that after doing five
years of archival research
you couldn't come
to the conclusion
that the empirical evidence
was largely on one side
and not on the other.
Yet I think that
actually many of us
have felt that we can't do that.
I would like to argue that
empirical and social causes do
play a role in all belief.
I think Bloor and
other colleagues
are correct about that.
But I also want to say that
it's an empirical question
as to how much of a role
they play in any given case.
And that is, historians, or
sociologists, or philosophers,
or literary theorists, we
could look at that question
and we might learn something
important if we did.
No, I think if we put it this
way it's actually obvious.
But I think the
shadow of symmetry
has made many STS scholars
have trouble, A, identifying
empirical causes,
and B, as taking them
as ever being determinative.
And that leads many to
assume that scientists'
claims about empirical
drivers and their beliefs
have to be viewed skeptically
not just as a starting point,
but at all times
in investigations.
And if you think I'm
creating a straw man,
and I'm very sensitive because
I hate it when academics create
straw mans, I'm
going to give you
an example to prove
that this is really
happening even as we speak.
So just this year some
colleagues in science studies
criticized consensus
studies, including my own,
as taking the side of
scientists or assuming the truth
value of their
claims, and therefore
as being illegitimate
intellectually.
So I want to argue that
these attitudes contribute
to what Stephen Colbert
famously called truthiness
in a good deal of
literature about science.
And that, of course, leads
to postmodernism in general.
So without getting into a big
debate about postmodernism
and how much it has or
has not influenced larger
cultural and political
trends, I think
it is fair to say, or
at least to suggest,
or at least to
raises a question,
that by de-stabilising
notions of truth and facts,
postmodernism has made
it more difficult for us
to talk about what is wrong with
things like the NELA propaganda
campaign.
And I want to argue that
that's problematic both
empirically and morally.
Empirically because a
fetishistic attachment
to symmetry and certain
postmodern ideals can lead us--
not necessarily, but I
think it often does--
into an ahistorical
false equivalence,
and morally because it
becomes very difficult, if not
impossible, to make a credible
case for why an industry should
be held accountable for
damage caused by its products.
And I may be wrong
about this, and if I am,
and if you think there's a way
to solve this using symmetry
or post-modernism,
then let's have
that conversation because I
think that would be great.
So I just want to
end with one example
that I think is
important and compelling.
And that's the
question of lead paint.
I think it's fair
to say that we all
know that lead paint interferes
with children's brain
development.
But if we ask the question,
how do we know this?
The answer has to
be that we know it
through the work of our
scientific and public health
colleagues.
Through the consensus
of experts--
our colleagues in
the medical school,
our colleagues in the
school of public health,
and scientists, and
medicine doctors,
and public health
officials in hospitals,
and medical schools, and
public health schools
all across this country who have
weighed the available evidence
and concluded that it
demonstrates that when
infants and young children
are exposed to lead it
affects their brain development.
But if we can't invoke hybrid
social cognitive categories
such as consensus, much
less empirical categories
such as evidence, then we're
hamstrung in any effort
to explain why we are warranted
in saying that lead paint leads
to brain damage in children.
Now of course, there
are many other issues
that are raised by the things
I've talked about tonight,
and I've written a talk that
I hope is sort of deliberately
provocative and there
are many other things we
could talk about.
And one of the things
I haven't talked about
is the problem that we don't
want to be accused of bias.
And of course, as academics
that's a real problem.
We want to, as much
as possible, being way
different points of view,
and not, as Bloor said,
presuppose that we know that
the answer to a question
is one thing or another.
But I will leave you with
one final thought, something
that the great Ashley
Montague said a long time ago,
reality has a
well-known liberal bias.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Sure.
Yeah, great.
Does Homi get the prerogative
of the first question?
Yes, he does, as
a matter of fact.
So I'm actually just sitting
up here to keep you company.
Oh that's nice of you.
In this crowd I
can't imagine there
aren't plenty of questions to
get the conversation started.
Well, I just want
to say thank you.
I thought that was
incredibly interesting,
and also a cautionary tale.
At this moment when
we're searching
for a new president for
this great university,
one of the issues that
arise in many conversations
is what is the relationship
between the university
and industry?
Which is a boundary that's being
redrawn at many institutions
and in different ways
within our own institution.
And so you've provided us
with quite a sobering story
about that relationship.
So I thought that
was very timely,
and I thank you for that.
I was also reminded of a passage
that occurs early on your book
on continental
drift, where you talk
about the tendency of historians
to regard truth as contingent
through a very
pithy paragraph, I
wish I could remember
the exact wording.
And then the tendency
of scientists
to want to arrive
at truth, which
is not linked to time and
space in that localized way.
And you ask whether or not
it's possible to resolve this,
and in some sense you're still
at this very difficult question
about how we reconcile
that understanding.
Yeah.
Well, that's true.
I mean, I think part of the
key to an academic career
is to dig your teeth
into juicy questions
that you can live
with for a long time.
Questions that will justify,
in a sense, a long marriage.
So yeah, I think that I have
come back to that question
repeatedly in different ways.
And that feels like a
really satisfying thing
to be able to do.
No, I agree with you.
The great questions
are not questions
we then answer and move
on to other things.
And that's why I don't--
--push us us through
an entire life.
And that's why I've
never understood
scientists or academics who are
territorial about their work.
I mean, if the
question is big enough,
then there's room for
a lot of people, right?
Homi, do you have a question?
So Naomi, I was absolutely
both terrified and entertained.
[LAUGHTER] Really
you hit a lot of--
you ticked off a lot of a very
good, very important boxes.
And this talk was
particularly sobering
on a day on which I read this
morning, I think in The Wall
Street Journal while I was on
a plane, that 46% of voters
believe that Trump is being
represented by the media
as peddling fake news,
when in fact the fakery
is on the part of the media.
46%.
Now you know, polls change.
And then 31% thought
that Trump and a lot
of his anti-regulation
team, et cetera,
were in fact that the truth
was not on their side,
that they were
manipulating facts, 31.
And the rest were undecided.
And that's a very
sobering thought.
And we can come back to that
any way in which you like.
But what your talk
made me think about
was this kind of repetitive
cycle of the manipulation
of news, values, the
manipulation of it
by special interests,
particularly
those of free market capital
in the name of freedom
and the individual.
And at each time
when this happens,
there is a mass of evidence
that this is happening.
People know it,
just as we do today.
We know it, and yet 46% think
that Trump is telling the truth
and is being misrepresented
by the media.
So the issue here really
is one of ideology
as much as it is of
science, as you said.
But what is it about
the resistance,
about this repetitive resistance
of the ideology of freedom
which allows people
to fantasize--
and I'm being very biased here--
to fantasize that their
freedoms are being taken away,
their individual privacy is
being threatened, and so on.
Now I just want to
say, I don't believe--
I mean, people have described
me as a postmodernist
ever since I was
more or less born.
You were born postmodern.
But I am not.
And to condemn
myself even further,
I would say if
there is anything,
I've been a post-structuralist,
not a postmodernist.
And there is a big
difference between the two.
But if there is one thing that
a lot of the jejune claims
of postmodernism gets right,
if there's one thing--
and I very much oppose-- there's
a postmodernism of everything.
There's a postmodernism
of shoe production,
postmodernism of
movies, or architecture.
But if there's one
thing it suggests
is that iterative processes
which are non-teleological
can raise questions
about truth or reality
in a contextual framework.
So iteration is not
about the notion
of a kind of evolutionary
or continuous system
leading to a certain
teleological notion
of freedom or whatever.
And so in that
case, I would have
thought that you
could have harnessed
certain ideas of
temporality and technology,
and temporality and
truth, against those
who run the wagons straight
in a kind of teleological line
towards the notion of freedom.
So I thought certain
concepts of postmodernism
could be valuable
to your inquiry
and disrupt this
notion of truth,
and linearity, and teleology
in which a lot of these claims
are made.
But my real question
is, why can't we--
my question's what
I said earlier.
Why are we, when we have
all the evidence, why
do people still want to hold on
to their ideological beliefs,
even when they're
self-destructive?
And your talk has shown that
this is a cyclical process.
It's not an evolutionary
or teleological.
And today we see this
more than ever before.
Yeah, I agree.
That's a really
important question.
And I think in a way that's
what I like from this talk,
I'd like to have
that conversation,
because I don't know
the answer to that.
And I wouldn't even
begin to think I could
start to answer it tonight.
But I think those are the kinds
of questions that we really
need to be talking about.
And those questions
don't get asked
most of the time
about climate change.
I've gone to hundreds of
conferences about climate
change in the last decade,
and that question never
gets asked, the question
of why Americans
can be persuaded that
regulating carbon dioxide
threatens their freedom.
Or like we say in the
film, how Americans
could be enrolled as allies--
so here I'll use
the tour, right?
I mean, Americans were
enrolled as allies
in the defense of the
interests of the tobacco
industry against their own
interests in public health
because they were
persuaded by the argument
that their freedom
was somehow at stake.
So it proves that it's an
extremely powerful argument.
And so we have to
take that on board,
and we have to realize that
if that's what's going on--
and in some ways it's too
bad more of our scientific
colleagues here, but this is
part of what I've been trying
to say to the
scientific community--
if that's what's going on, then
no amount of charts and graphs
about death, tobacco-related
mortality and morbidity--
will solve this problem.
Because if I think my freedom
is being threatened by tobacco
regulation, I'm not
going to be influenced
by an argument about tobacco
morbidity and mortality.
And it's the same
with climate change.
If I think that
the Democrats want
to tell me where I can
live, and where I can work,
and what car I
can drive, I'm not
going to be influenced
by an argument that
says, oh, but look at
the sea level rise,
you know, this sea
level has risen
another inch since this decade,
or this rate of sea level rise
has doubled, or look at
the exponential growth
in the rate of sea level
rise in North Carolina.
No, that's going to
be irrelevant to me.
Because I believe that my
freedom is being threatened.
And so that's part of the point
of this argument is to say--
it's a category error to
think that this problem can
be addressed with
more scientific data
if what's fundamentally
at stake it's
people's ideological
commitments and their beliefs
about the character
of American culture.
And it's linked also to not
just the idea of freedom
in an abstract way,
but to a belief
that what makes America great,
what makes life in America
great, is that we're
a free country,
and that we have a level of
freedom that is unmatched
anywhere in the world.
Whether or not that claim is
true is not the relevant point.
The claim is that that claim
is persuasive for many people.
So I think this is an
incredibly helpful way
to reframe what's going
on around climate change.
It leads me, anyway,
to think that this
is a view into, in some
sense, the unconscious of them
problem, the sort of social
unconscious of the problem.
But it does make me wonder
whether the iterations are
exactly the same.
Whether what's underlying
the resistance to climate
change really can--
we can hang that on the
same ideology of freedom.
And this is really an
open question about
whether or not that's true, but
it's a very intriguing idea.
And I think the
other question that's
related that arises for me is
the age old question of why
Americans are so
suspicious of government
control over their lives
and not corporate control
over their lives,
especially now.
I mean, really?
Like, it's the government
that's controlling your life?
It's not Facebook,
it's not-- you know.
And that may change.
I mean, we live in an
interesting moment,
because people are
starting to talk
about the ways in which
Facebook or Google have access
to all this information,
and your privacy
is probably more threatened
by them than the government
because they are probably
more efficient to gather
information.
But just about the
returning of certain themes.
I mean, I always say, history
is neither a line nor a cycle,
it's a spiral.
So we spiral back around
to certain themes,
but of course, they're
never exactly the same.
The arguments about
freedom in 2017
are not going to be exactly
the same as the arguments
about freedom in
1937, but there are
going to be certain family
resemblances, right?
And we do see certain words and
certain motifs being recycled.
And the fact that they
are recycled and seem
to be recycled with
effect is telling us
something about certain
kinds of persistent patterns
in American culture.
May I just throw one thing
in here please, just one
quick thing?
We've been talking
about freedom.
But I think the issue is
not freedom in general.
I think there's a specific
thing that's come out
which is the freedom of choice.
And I think that's
a different thing
from just thinking
about freedom,
because it's so much linked
to the market ideologies.
So I think the specific
form of freedom
that people always
feel threatened about
is freedom of choice.
Not freedom of movement,
or freedom of speech,
but my choice is being
somehow determined.
Other questions?
Yeah?
Thank you, Jed
Schwarzman, Somerville.
Thank you for that
reference to David Bloor,
I never heard of him, and
I'm supposedly in sociology.
[LAUGHTER] Presuming that the
Wall Street Journal report
about 46% favoring
Trump is correct,
which I think it's
probably a fair assumption.
But the essence of a news
report is much more difficult
than the rejection of the
completeness of a news report.
So that if you deconstruct
Trump's it's fake news
to it's not an adequate report,
that in fact is much easier
to accept, and in fact, is truer
than a claim that a report from
a news report--
any news report--
is a complete and adequate
depiction of what happened.
I'm just trying to explain--
not defend Trump, but to explain
why it's actually slightly--
I mean, if you change it from
fake news to it's not adequate,
then it makes more sense that
people actually believe him
because there's a
skepticism about reality
in the country as a whole.
And that that's the
essence of my comment.
Thanks very much.
Questions?
I read On Liberty by
Jon Stewart last week,
and I was going over my notes.
And in the last section he
has one little paragraph where
he talks about the
main laws, which were--
I'm sorry, the what laws?
The main laws.
Which evidently were about
regulations to selling liquor.
And the preface to
his little paragraph
is, the person who
is selling a product
has a vested interest in your
buying that product, maybe
against their own interests
that want to sell more of that.
And I thought that was
really interesting.
He doesn't elaborate on that,
but that was interesting.
Let me give you some references.
George Seldes and in
fact, from the 1930s
on talking, about
cigarette smoking.
Really interesting.
I think this stuff also goes
back into the 1850s and John
Stuart Mill talking maybe
possibly about morphine
and opium.
Talking about liquor.
Lead, Thomas Midgley, Jr.
Could we get a question?
I just want to give
you these references.
Thomas Midgely, Jr. and
the lead in gasoline,
testifying before
Congress while he's
suffering from lead poisoning,
saying there's no problem.
What is interesting to me is for
over a decade I've been saying,
solar is civil defense.
It doesn't matter what you
believe about climate change.
We know that there's going
to be a weather emergency,
and therefore we should
have a light, you know,
a phone or radio.
You can do that with a
couple of inches of PV panel
and you're set.
So if you talk
about that, you're
moving towards a transition.
But I say this to Michael Mann
last year, climate scientist,
and I say, this gets us
out of the right fighting,
the argument.
What do you think of that?
And he says, no.
They have to believe
the science, right?
So what is it about us
that we would rather
fight about truth and falsity
rather than do something
that we all know is a
legitimate precaution, whatever
we believe about climate?
Yeah, that's a great question.
I can't speak for
Mike Mann, but I
will say the following about
our scientific colleagues.
And I think I can
say this because I
used to be one of them, or
sort of still am in some ways.
When you're raised
as a scientist,
you're raised to believe
that knowledge is power.
Goes back to bacon.
And that idea is so
deeply ingrained that
to accept that it might not
be, to accept that you might do
the greatest, best, most
elegant, most powerful
scientific analysis in the
world and people would just
say to you, [SCOFFS]
I don't believe it,
the cognitive dissonance
created by that
is so profound
that I don't think
most scientists can bear it.
Because if you really
come to grips with it,
your whole world
potentially collapses.
Because then why are
you working so hard?
And it's hard being a scientist.
I mean, those of us in the
humanities and social sciences,
we can moan and groan about
how we don't get paid as much,
or we don't get loved as much.
But the reality is our
scientific colleagues
work unbelievably
hard and spend a lot
of time hustling for money.
Why are you doing all that if
you don't believe in your heart
that the knowledge
that you produce
will be used by people in
meaningful and effective ways?
And when you see the evidence
of the way in which that doesn't
happen, I think if you
come to grips with it,
it's kind of crushing, actually.
So I think many scientists
don't come to grips with it.
And even people I
know well, people
I consider friends, people
who I consider sophisticated,
will still say things to me at
the end of the day like, well,
but I still believe you know
at the end of the day society
will have to act on this,
people will have to accept this.
And you know, I want
that to be true.
But as an historian,
I don't believe it is.
As an historian, I think, you
know, this could go either way.
It could be that people accept
it and we convert our energy
system, and it could
be we don't, and we
have the collapse of Western
civilization scenario.
And that's partly why
I wrote that book.
Because I wanted people
to see what it looked
like if you took
seriously the possibility
that we completely failed
to act on what we know.
And so that's the
motif of the book.
The historian of the future
who is asking the question, how
is it possible they did
so much and did so little?
Other questions?
Yeah?
This gal over here's been
waiting for a while, too,
so you might next time call her.
Yeah, go ahead.
Hi, we've spoken a
lot about the role
of the scientist in the process
of media production of what
is truth.
Could you speak a
little bit about how
you might have encountered
the artist, so to speak
in your historical research?
And in addition to
that, what role you
think art might play in
navigating post-truth politics?
Well I want to start
by saying I think
art has a huge role to play.
It's one of the few areas
I'm optimistic about.
And I know I saw Carson
Kreitzer was here earlier,
and looks like she's left.
But she's writing a play right
now about climate change,
and she did a reading
with actors yesterday
that I went to, and it was
so exciting and thrilling.
So I hope that if her
play gets produced at ART,
you all go and see it.
I think it's
incredibly important,
because I think it's
one of the places where
we are able to actually
think through questions
in ways that can get
us out of the boxes
that we walked in with.
And good art, when
it's effective,
reaches people in part
because it frames a question
in a different way than we
thought about it before.
Or it suggests
different possibilities.
And one of the things that's so
difficult about climate change,
I mean, lots of
people these days
have been quoting
Frederick Jamison.
We can imagine the
end of the world
more easily than we can
imagine the end of capitalism.
And the crazy thing about it
is that I think he's right.
I mean, he's right.
And it's true of me.
When I was writing The Collapse
of Western Civilization,
it was actually quite
easy to sort of imagine
how this whole thing just
goes to hell in a handbasket.
But then when you start
to think about how
we could do something different,
which is what I'm working on
now with my post-doc Geoffrey
Supran who was here earlier,
oh, it's so much harder.
I mean, so much harder.
And I don't know why
that is, but it is.
But then if you think about
art and creative work,
I mean, what is
it that art does?
Well, one of the
things it does is
to help us imagine things that
we didn't previously imagine.
So I think it's
hugely important.
And so if you're an
artist, or if you're
thinking about being an
artist, or if you know artists,
that's where I'm pinning
some of my hopes now.
That might be a lot of
pressure, because I really
don't think the solution--
well, I don't want to say this.
I think there's a
lot of possible ways
in which things
can also go well,
and I don't give up hope
that there could be--
I mean, I am very
optimistic about batteries.
Like, I'm not saying that
technological solutions
won't play an important role.
I think they will.
But I don't think that
more scientific information
is going to be determinative
at this point in history.
Yeah?
[INAUDIBLE] so I'm
that kind of artist.
I was intrigued by your
phrase, social subconscious.
Because all during
the conversation
about why Americans
are doing this,
you haven't talked about
the rest of the world
where it's much
less of a problem
to be obsessed with
personal freedom.
So this is a kind of psychosis.
And I'm wondering if of
all the other scientists
you want to bring
into this discussion,
where are the psychiatrists?
Our culture needs to
be psychoanalyzed.
[LAUGHTER] Have you
thought about that?
Yeah, absolutely.
So two things.
So first of all, part of
the way I got involved
in this whole thing in the first
place was about 10 years ago,
I was doing a project with a
group of colleagues in England.
It was an international
group that
was based at London
School of Economics,
and I was flying to
London pretty regularly
going like two or
three times a year.
And you'd get off the
airplane at Heathrow
and there were these
big giant signs
that said BP, Beyond Petroleum.
And it was like going
to a parallel universe.
It was like literally
living in a different world.
And my friends in
Europe would say to me,
what is wrong with America?
Like, what the heck
is going on there?
And so part of this
project became a project
to try to understand why the
United States was viewing
this question in
such a different way
than really any other
country in the world.
There's no other country, and
Australia had some problems.
Canada was a bit bad under
the Harper government.
But really there isn't
any country in the world
where people reject
the evidence of climate
change the way we do here
in the United States.
So that was part of the problem,
was to try to understand this.
And again, that's what
brings me back to the idea
that this is essentially
a humanistic and social
scientific question.
This is a question why Americans
reject climate science, right?
And that's not a question that
climate scientists can answer.
That's a question that social
scientists, and humanists,
and artists might
be able to answer.
And maybe psychiatrists, right?
So in terms of
psychiatry, I'm not one,
but some of my best friends are.
Robert Jay Lifton has
a new book that's just
come out on exactly this issue.
So if you haven't read
it, it's a must read.
He's coming to--
Good, oh good, I'm
glad to hear that.
Excellent I think his
work is really important.
And there have been others, too.
I mean, there's a
group of psychiatrists
who have been having
this discussion now
about Donald Trump,
most in relation
to the nuclear weapons.
[INAUDIBLE],, our colleague, had
a letter in the New York Times
the other day, but I
know that he's also
thinking about climate change.
So I think there are people, but
you know, it's a tricky thing.
Because psychiatrists
don't want to psychoanalyze
individual people, but
then group psychology,
well, that's a real thing.
So I do think there are
things to be done there.
It's not my field, but I
do think it's important.
The other thing I
was going to say
is Amitav Ghosh's recent
book, A Great Derangement--
I mean, I love that book, and
I think it's such a great title
because he's right.
There's a way in which
this is deranged.
We're destroying our homes,
we're burning down our houses.
And if you went home tonight
and set your house on fire
you would be considered crazy.
And you will probably be--
your family or friends, if
you had family or friends,
would try to get you
psychiatric help.
And if you didn't have
family and friends
you might be arrested
as an arsonist.
But you would be considered
a mentally unstable person.
So we're burning down our house.
And yet somehow
that's normal, right?
So I think that thinking of
it as a kind of derangement
is actually a very
powerful way of getting
at some of these
questions about why we're
doing the things
we're doing, and why
we seem to be locked
into certain patterns--
certain patterns of
behavior, certain patterns
of economic activity, and we
can't imagine an alternative.
Yeah?
So I have two questions.
Do we need to
enlighten the masses,
or do we need to properly
propagandize the masses?
Good question.
Well, that's a
really good question.
And I guess--
And is there a difference?
I guess I'd like to argue for
something like true propaganda.
I mean, obviously part
of the reason this works
is because NELA told
the story about a threat
to things that people valued.
That slide that I showed
more than once deliberately
of the cute little
boy looks a little bit
like JFK Jr. with these things.
The message is, these are things
you care about, your children,
your freedom, your
freedom of religion.
And these things are threatened.
And that's a story.
It's a narrative, and
it was a powerful one
that we think we have
evidence was influential,
at least to some degree.
And there's been a lot of
talk about this in the climate
change community, right?
The climate scientists
don't have a narrative.
They have facts,
they have figures,
but they don't have a story
about why this matters.
So to the extent that one can
tell a true story about why
this matters, why things you
care about are threatened,
because that's the truth, right?
I mean, the NELA story
about the threats to freedom
could be flipped on its head.
There's a story about
things we care about
and things we love that are
threatened by climate change.
But climate scientists never
talk about love, right?
The day I knew I was
going to be a historian
was the day that I
said in a seminar,
why don't we ever
talk about love?
And it was like, you could
have heard a pin drop.
But I mean, I became a
geologist because I loved rocks.
That's the honest to
God truth of the matter.
And I love being
outdoors, and I love
that sense of being connected
to the natural world,
and that sense of feeling that
I actually understood something
really deep and
profound that I could
feel the sense of emotional
connection to geological time.
Those were all very
emotional things for me.
But scientists never
talk about that,
because that's considered
at odds with models
of scientific rationality.
But that stands in the
way of communication.
Because if you talk to
anyone in communication,
anyone in marketing,
anyone in advertisement,
anyone in Hollywood,
they will all tell you,
communication isn't
about the facts,
it's about [THUMP] right?
It's about getting people
here, or here, right?
It's about what you
feel in the gut.
And if you see a
movie that's powerful,
it's because it moves
you emotionally,
not because somebody made
a good argument, right?
So I think that's
part of the challenge.
So I guess my
answer to you is, I
think we do need
to tell stories,
but I don't think
we have to lie.
I don't think we have to
make up BS because the facts,
the truth are bad enough, right?
Because I get asked
that question too.
Like, should scientists
be more alarmist?
We don't need to
be more alarmist.
The truth is alarming enough.
So just stick with
the truth, but tell it
in a way that is compelling and
that connects it to the things
that people care about.
Yeah?
Just like a couple
of more questions.
So two other kind of prominent
instances of science denial
that I can really think
of off the top of my head
are maybe vaccines and
GMOs, which maybe you
have arguments or
freedom but from a kind
of against corporate interests.
So I was wondering
if you've looked
into the history of those and
how those kind of instances
come about and are different
from the climate problem,
or similar.
Yeah, I haven't done that
much research on them
but I've certainly read
the work of my colleagues
have written them.
So first of all I want
to say on GMOs, GMOs
are not a case of
science denial.
That's what Monsanto
wants you to think.
But the reality
is that GMOs raise
a lot of complicated issues.
One issue is whether or
not they're safe to eat.
And that is a
scientific question.
And we do have a fair amount
of scientific evidence
that suggests that probably
for most people in most cases
they're probably safe
to eat, although I
think one could still raise
some questions about that.
And I don't think we
have really good data
to identify some people for
whom they might not be safe.
But overall the
scientific evidence
does say that they're probably
safe for most people to eat.
So if you were to say
GMOs are not safe to eat,
that would be science denial.
But there are a
lot of people who
are opposed to GMOs for all
kinds of reasons that have
nothing to do with food safety.
And the GMO industry
Monsanto have
been trying to collapse
this all down to food safety
in order to claim that it's
a case of science denial
and discredit other
kinds of issues that
are being raised about GMO.
So my favorite example is, if
you read the Papel Encyclical
on Climate Change, Pope Francis
is against genetically modified
crops.
Has nothing to do
with food safety.
with science at all.
It's not a scientific question.
It's a theological argument.
You might agree with it,
you might disagree with it.
You might like it, you
might think it's stupid,
but it's not science denial.
So I think that's really
important to be clear about.
Vaccine rejection is science
denial in my opinion.
The best book on that is our
colleague Seth Mnookin at MIT,
who wrote this book,
The Panic Virus, which
is a really great sensitive
investigation of the families
of people whose
children have autism
and who believe that
their autism was
caused by vaccinations.
So really, really worth reading.
It's kind of a
model of how you can
be sensitive to the concerns
and experiences of people
without necessarily going native
and accepting their accounts
of what's happened to them.
So I highly recommend that book.
But here's the really
interesting thing
about vaccine rejection--
I think rejection is probably
a better word than denial.
Even though vaccine rejection is
a real phenomenon United States
and it's having public
health consequences,
it's still actually pretty mild.
It's pretty moderate,
there's only about 5%
of Americans that don't get
their children vaccinated.
Now from a public
health perspective,
that's problematic.
Because once you get down to
about 90% vaccination rates,
you begin to lose herd immunity
and people are at risk.
So 5% to 10% of
vaccine rejection
is a serious public
health issue,
but it still means that
90% to 95% of Americans
are getting their vaccinations.
So that's wildly different
than climate change where
something like maybe
40% or 50% of us
are rejecting the
scientific findings,
or creationism where depending
on how you ask the question,
anywhere from 50%
to 95% of Americans
have views that are at odds with
what evolutionary biologists
think is correct.
So it's a really, really
different kind of case.
And now add one
more piece to it.
So in the case of
vaccinations, you
have the industry is aligned
with science and public health.
But imagine if that
weren't the case.
Imagine if industry were
on the side of saying
that vaccines cause autism.
In my opinion, then
we wouldn't just
have 5% of Americans
rejecting it.
Then in my opinion we
would have a public health
crisis of colossal proportions.
So part of the lesson
of this whole story
is you have to look at
the alignments, right?
You have to look at what are
the political alignments, what
are the economic alignments,
where is power lining up?
The fossil fuel industry
is incredibly powerful.
And that's one of the
reasons-- not the only reason,
but it's one of the reasons
why doubt and disinformation
about climate change persists.
Because you have very,
very powerful corporations
spending lots and lots of money
to keep those arguments alive.
Now, creationism
is a bit different.
There isn't a kind of
creationist industry.
But there are some
powerful-- yeah, exactly.
There isn't a kind of
private sector of creationism
in quite the same way that
we have private sector
fossil fuel.
But there is a kind of
industry, there's certainly
a big social movement.
So there it's a kind of
difference of alignments,
they're more social
alignments, I would say,
[INAUDIBLE] is
nodding, so OK, good.
But the point is, though,
that's if you really
want to understand
any of these issues,
they're not all the same.
They're not all just, oh,
people reject science.
There are more complicated
dynamics going on.
And so I think it's
not necessarily
helpful to lump
them all together.
I'll just give one
other example of this.
I did give a talk
recently where I
talked a little bit about
GMOs, and I used this example.
National Geographic magazine
about a couple of years
ago how to cover
story, some of you
may have seen, which they
called the war on science.
I'm not personally fond
of warfare metaphors,
so I didn't really love
that to begin with.
But then they had
a list of claims,
and the claims were,
climate change is not real,
evolution didn't happen,
vaccines cause autism,
GMOs are evil.
And I'm like, what?
This is like Big Bird
singing, which of these things
doesn't belong?
I mean, GMOs are evil
is a moral claim.
Might be true, might be false.
But it's not a scientific
question, right?
But yet it's being conflated by
National Geographic magazine,
who you would have thought
would know better, right?
Good question.
Yeah?
Ian.
Thank you, Naomi.
The talk was convincing,
eloquent, exciting,
and a lot of fun.
I never thought about
hats in that way before.
[LAUGHTER]
There you go.
So I'm convinced that the
kind of eloquent statements
about the role of capitalism
and enterprise capitalism
in particular, I find
that very convincing,
and the invocation of the Papal
Encyclical points me to one way
to explore the historical
particularity of this--
and this isn't my
question, so it's
a prompt to further thought.
And that is, if both
of these examples
are inherent to a
capitalist moment
and a particular expression of
an American capitalism, then
what happens if we push
earlier when we get in debates
over heterodoxy and orthodoxy?
In the papacy,
for example, do we
see similar techniques
being put to work,
or is there something
inherent to this moment
and this culture?
And how has that come
up in your thinking?
And if it hasn't,
then perhaps this
is something we could think with
our colleagues in the Divinity
School about as we move ahead.
My question, though, has
to do less with capitalism,
more with energy.
So Lenin famously
said, communism
equals Soviet power
plus electricity.
The apotheosis of his project.
And so that led me
to think, OK, we've
got to think differently
about capitalism here,
or what's going on with
the electrical stuff.
And that's my question,
and it's quite open.
I'm interested in
hearing you think
out loud about what's particular
about the electricity here?
Or if that's too narrow,
then it strikes me
that two of our
four main examples
are energy questions,
fossil fuels and climate
change, electricity and doubt,
and the freedom of the market
and so why fully 50%
of these examples
and are coming out of a
key sector of the economy.
And that's what I'd be
interested in hearing about.
What about the energy,
what about electricity?
Yeah.
It's a great question, and
I don't know the answer.
And like I said,
this is early stages.
So this is really great
to have this feedback it's
something I've
thought about, but I
don't know what the answer is.
But what is it about
electricity, right?
Because there's a whole set of
ideologies around electricity,
right?
And that quotation
is such a great one.
This idea that electricity
is so uniquely powerful
that if you can harness it,
you can do all kinds of things.
You can make the
communist utopia,
but you could also make the
rural American utopia, as well,
right?
I mean, isn't that amazing?
Both Gifford Pinchot and Lenin
think that their problems can
be solved through electricity.
So in class today, my
technology seminar,
we had a whole
discussion today about
technological determinism.
And this gets to this really
tricky question in history,
right?
So as historians we
don't like determinism.
We think everything in life
is complicated, which it is.
But yet there is something
about certain technologies
that seemingly make people
think that there's something
inherently or innately
powerful about them.
And I think you see
this today in a lot
of the discussion
around computers and AI
as well, right?
But but you see this in
electricity so powerfully,
and even the word power, right?
The way the word power means
both the fuel, the electricity,
the fossil fuel, the coal,
but also the political power.
And is it a coincidence that
we use the same word for both?
You know, that would be worth
doing some investigation.
When did the word power
come to mean what we got out
of burning fossil fuels?
And when--
1970s.
No, it's way before the 1970s.
I would say it might be the
1870s, or might be the 1770s,
I don't know.
But I mean, this would be a
useful thing to think about.
But electrical power,
energy, thermodynamic power
is very closely
linked with concepts
of cultural and
political power as well.
And you see this in the
Industrial Revolution as well.
And this is where I'm getting,
like, way outside my field,
right?
But when people are talking
about the power of coal,
when people are talking
about railroads,
about electrification,
these motifs come back about
how these things are going
to be transformative, right?
And even the word transformer.
So the analogies, the language--
so I think I need to do
a lot more work on that.
And I hope we can think
through this together because I
think it's really important.
And maybe if we
could crack that,
we could also crack
some of these questions
about why people view technology
as being so determinative.
And one would want
to think about
whether energy is really
the key point of kinship
in those examples,
or whether it's
the interdependence and
the networking that's
involved in both examples.
Because if there's
one thing that's
challenging to American
ideology around capitalism,
it's that your choice
affects other peoples
in ways that should then
rebound to have effects
on your capacity to
choose, whether it's
burning fossil fuels, or
whether it's an electrical grid.
Right, well that's like
the famous Isaiah Berlin
line about freedom for
wolves is death to sheep.
And I used that line once when
I was talking at the Yellowstone
coalition, and I thought,
oh, bad metaphor here, right?
But I think that's true.
But I also think there's
just this other thing
about the notion of
the natural monopoly,
like, that's a really
interesting phrase, too.
Read Monopolies
are supposed to be
bad in enterprise capitalism.
But yet we have these
things like electricity,
and railroads, and
telephone, and telegraph
that don't seem to work well
in a free enterprise system.
So what do you do?
You say they are
natural monopolies.
So somehow you
separate them out.
It's natural for that
to be a monopoly,
so therefore you allow
it to be a monopoly,
but then you immediately have
the problem of regulation.
Because once you allow
it to be a monopoly,
then it has to be regulated.
But people don't
like regulation,
so then you get the corruption
of regulatory agencies,
and on it goes.
We'll take one last question.
Thanks for your talk, Naomi.
I'll offer really quick
and preliminary suggestion
as to the origins of
the power question.
Oh good, yes, excellent.
Basically horsepower.
Once we start using it
as a unit to measure
the capacity of our steam
machines and the like.
But my question goes to sort
of the origins of this project,
and what you presented earlier.
You said that you were
really interested in how
did these people, this cast
of characters in Merchants
of Doubt, for instance,
sleep at night,
and try to humanize
them in a way.
And it seems as if your
presentation of NELA here,
it's almost like
COBRA in GI Joe.
It's just so nefarious.
And I'm wondering whether,
as you've done your research,
and--
I mean, I know you're at
the early stages of this--
how your understanding of
this new cast of characters
may be different from the
one that you had presented
in your earlier work.
And maybe it's a way
of then getting to--
I mean, with the ones in in
Giant Power here, I mean,
do these people really believe
in this kind of freedom
that they sell?
And for Merchants of Doubt,
whether those proselytizers
of freedom, who actually--
and I know it's difficult to get
to the question of intention,
but to the extent
that you have been
able to see in your sources?
Yeah, that's a great question.
I think it's too soon to tell.
I don't have the source material
yet to start getting into that.
I think when I get into some
of the archives, particularly
the universities that
worked with these people,
we may be able to see
a little bit better
what some of the justifications,
understandings are
and begin to complexify
the story a little bit
and make them not
so black and white.
Right now I don't have the
material to do that yet.
But I think the
other thing also,
if I think about how I
think about it so far--
and this, as I said,
is early days--
but I do see NELA as being
more like the tobacco industry
than like Bill Nuremberg
and Fred Singer, I mean,
one of the things that's
interesting about this story
is, so the entry into the
Merchants of Doubt story
was a group of men,
people-- four individuals,
three of whom I knew personally.
So that's the other thing.
It's like a kind of
very weird backstory
to this whole thing about that
I actually knew these people.
And when I started realizing
what they were up to I thought,
what in the heck are they doing?
And then there was this
sort of weird almost
like destiny feeling, even
though I didn't really
believe in destiny.
I had come across this story.
I had met Erik and he had
this whole parallel story
about the ozone hole.
And then we looked at
who these people were,
and he sent me these
documents that he
had found in the
archives at Scripps,
which is where I was working.
And these were
all people I knew.
And right at the
beginning, when I was--
Erik sent me a pile of
materials that he had pulled out
of the archive that he hadn't
really done anything with.
And in fact, it's kind
of an ironic story.
He was writing a book on the
history of atmospheric science
at NASA.
And so he was writing about
the science, not about
the politics.
And so he had come across this
whole story about these attacks
on the scientists who had
worked on the ozone science.
And he had set it
aside because it
was this sort of political story
that wasn't part of his science
story.
And so when I met him
we started talking,
said, oh, yeah, I have all this
stuff about how Sherry Rowland
was attacked by these guys.
I'll send it to you.
And so he sends me this stuff,
and I open this envelope,
and I open the folder, and
the first page is a letter
on Dartmouth letterhead.
Now, my first job
was at Dartmouth.
And if you've ever seen
the Dartmouth letterhead,
you never forget it.
Because it's a picture of
Native Americans walking out
of the woods and
being enlightened
by the rays of knowledge
that are descending down
from the heavens
on these savages.
It's very distinctive.
And I saw this, I
thought, Dartmouth.
I thought, who at
Dartmouth is doing this?
And then I look at the
letter who's signing it,
it's Bob Jastrow, and he was
my colleague in my first job
at the earth science
department at Dartmouth.
So it was kind of
personal for me.
And the weird thing about
Jastrow-- two weird things.
So Jastrow was sort of persona
non grata in my department
at the time because
he was a creationist.
But he was an old earth
creationist, not a young earth
creationist.
But it was a little
bit of an anomaly.
So this is an earth
science department,
and we've got this guy in our
midst who's a creationist.
And he was a very
opinionated person.
Not the best colleague
in the world.
But I thought it was super
interesting-- and remember,
I'm coming as this sort
of hybrid geologist
historian of science.
So I arrive, and I'm so
young, and I'm so naive.
And I think it's
super interesting
that we have this creationist in
our midst, so I befriended him.
And I started talking
to him and asking him
questions about his beliefs.
And he starts telling
me what he believes,
and it's like straight out of
William Paley and 19th century
natural theology.
And I think to myself,
this is fantastic.
This guy is a living fossil!
[LAUGHTER] So I
spent a lot of time
talking to him about his views.
So I knew him kind of
well, and then he retired.
He retired a year after
I got there so we only
overlapped for a year.
And I knew that he had very
conservative political views.
He was sort of associate
with Dartmouth Review.
But I didn't really know
very much about that.
So now it's 15 years later, and
I said, this is Bob Jastrow.
So he's not just
a living fossil,
he's also involved in these
weird attacks on science.
And so one thing kind
of led to another.
And so those men were always
real people from me right from
the get-go, so that
in a way helped--
not to tell the story as a kind
of black hat, white hat story.
But as we dug in
the archives, and we
began to study their connections
with the tobacco industry,
and then connected to the
literature on the history
of tobacco like what Allen
Branch, and Robert Proctor,
and others have done, then
you read these things,
you read these tobacco
industry executives--
if I had had more time I was
going to throw in the clip that
shows the guys testifying
in Congress saying,
nicotine is not addictive,
nicotine is not addictive.
But then you think, OK, how
do these guys sleep at night,
right?
Because they know
they're selling a product
that is deadly and addictive.
And they testify under oath
that it's not addictive.
So I mean, these guys
are criminals, right?
And there are criminals
in the world, right?
Just like there
are conspiracies.
So then the historical task
gets to be, how can you
tell a story about people who
might actually be criminals,
or who might do criminal things
but still maintain a kind of--
I don't know,
historical nuance, I
guess would be the
right way of putting it?
And in the tobacco story, one
of things that makes that easier
to do is the fact
that these guys
were, in fact, prosecuted by
the US Department of Justice.
So they are criminals,
and I can say
that they're criminals
as a matter of fact,
as opposed to as a
matter of moral judgment.
So part of the challenge
of NELA is then
going to have to be
go back and that's
why I made the point
about what they did
wasn't criminal at
the time because there
were no laws against it.
But in 1935 a law
was passed that did
make those kinds of
activities criminal.
So the mention of
William Paley made
me look at my watch,
which I notice
is a highly designed mechanism.
But thank you so much.
I know you taught
just before this,
so we're so grateful for you
coming and doing this, Naomi.
It's a fabulous talk.
Thanks so much.
Thank you.